hey everybody welcome to app 203
introducing our new managed service for
prometheus my name is lee yanko i'm a
product manager within google cloud i'm
joined today by bartok jokovsky senior
devops engineer at openx
so today we're going to talk about some
challenges with prometheus we're going
to introduce google cloud and manage
service for prometheus do a bit of a
deep dive in the components of the
system talk about how it compares to
cloud monitoring and then openx is going
to talk about their journey with managed
service for prometheus so
challenges with prometheus
prometheus is great it works really well
there is a very good reason why it is
the de facto standard for kubernetes
monitoring
managing prometheus for small
deployments is pretty easy
managing prometheus at scale can be very
hard so
first of all prometheus can be hard to
scale horizontally when you have a small
cluster you just put a couple gigs of
ram in the server and it just works
your cluster gets a little larger you
have to scale up by throwing more ram at
the server eventually your cluster gets
so large that you have to shard by
front-end application and back-end
application or by a through m and
through z or something like that uh
somewhat interestingly for a cloud
native service prometheus doesn't have a
particularly good horizontal scaling
story
prometheus can be hard to make global so
when you're small and you only have a
few clusters it's no big deal you have a
couple different data sources within
grafana you swap between them it works
eventually you might want to get a
global view so you federate eventually
your prometheus deployment grows even
more so you have multiple federation
servers you might simplify it by
switching to thanos so you have thanos
querying your prometheus servers
and then you go hybrid or multi-cloud
and you have thanos querying thanos
querying your prometheus servers
and then somebody on your team adds user
id or ip address as a label cardinality
explodes and the whole thing falls over
which leads me to my third point
managing prometheus can be an ongoing
operational burden and a thankless task
your end customers do not care how good
you are at managing monitoring
infrastructure they care how good you
are keeping your app up of course
but the monitoring infrastructure part
is really a thankless task
none of this is hard
it's just toil it's work it's 20 to 30
hours of somebody's time every week in
perpetuity
here's the thing
google has been through this exact
experience ten years ago we also had a
system for monitoring where we had local
servers that federated into regional
servers that federated into global
servers
we built some new technology for
ourselves to solve this problem for
google and we're excited to share this
next generation prometheus compatible
solution with you
so we're introducing google cloud
managed service for prometheus a drop-in
replacement for prometheus and thanos
this is the managed service for
prometheus ecosystem
i'm going to use this to frame a
conversation about the different parts
of the system and how they benefit you
as a customer so in the center sits
monarch monarch is google's planet scale
time series metric storage and retrieval
database monarch is the same exact
system that we use to monitor internal
google so you know ads search networking
youtube google play you name it all use
monarch to make sure that their apps are
up and running and stable
we have a separate instance of monarch
called cloud monarch cloud monarch is
the same instance that's used by cloud
monitoring and management for prometheus
shares some of these cloud monitoring
apis and i'll get back to why that's
super interesting in a second
on the left side we have the collectors
so our collector is compatible anywhere
that prometheus runs because our
collector is prometheus it's prometheus
plus a couple hundred lines of code that
wrap things up in a proto and send it to
google so we have two different types of
collectors so the self-managed
collectors use your existing prometheus
operator configs to configure the
scraping
so you just copy paste those switch out
the binary and they just work if you're
in gke we also have manage collectors in
which case google will handle the
scaling the sharding the deployment of
these collectors and you configure the
scraping using crds
on the query side uh because we have
implemented prom ql your existing
grafana dashboard is written in promql
just work your prometheus alerts and
alert manager configs just work and your
prom cool base tools any prompts tool
that you might find on the internet any
community curated dashboard any random
alert template you might want to use
just works
and because we're using the same apis
and backend systems as cloud monitoring
your cloud monitoring metrics your free
metrics your free bigquery your free
anthos your free sdo your free data flow
your free pub sub whatever you use
those metrics will be accessible within
grafana using prongql right alongside
your prometheus metrics giving you a
single pane of glass
and likewise because we're using the
same backend system your prometheus
metrics will also be available within
cloud monitoring so you can use advanced
features such as slo alerting cloud
alerting our dashboard builder etc with
your prometheus metrics in cloud
monitoring
we built this to be as drop-in of a
replacement as possible so that you can
keep doing what you're doing and just
outsource the hard part the metric
storage and retrieval part to us
now let's do a bit of a deep dive with
some of the components here so let's
talk about monarch the planet scale in
memory time series database it's the
same tool we use to monitor internal
google monarch has over a trillion time
series in ram 14 quadrillion points on
disk writes two and a half terabytes a
second processes 16 million queries per
second
whatever you can throw at us we can
handle promise
monarch is configured for two-year
retention uh included for all metrics by
default and monarch has regional storage
with ad hoc global aggregations at query
time so if you say you want your data to
live in cloud zone x your data will live
in cloud zone x
on the collection side where compatible
anywhere prometheus is deployed there's
two flavors managed for gke environments
and self-hosted for other kubernetes
environments this means that managed
service for prometheus is hybrid and
multi-cloud
compatible from the very beginning
our collectors are open source so you
can see what's writing within your
clusters of course and there's no need
to store any data locally so you can use
way less ram to run these collectors
than normal prometheus
on the query side we're fully prom ql
compatible so your existing grafana
dashboards just work you can query your
free gcp metrics alongside your
prometheus metrics getting you a single
pane glass and read permissions are
enforced on groups of projects at query
time so this is really nice for
customers that have uh tenants of their
own so you can do something like send
tenant ones metrics to project a
sentence twos metrics to project b and
then you have a separate permissions
that has both project a and b included
for your sre teams to get a global view
across all your tenants
on the alerting recording rule side we
work with prometheus alert manager out
of the box we work with promql based
alerts and recording rules anything you
might have developed already out of the
box
and we are compatible with google
cloud's alerting as well
so as you can see here we built an
interactive query ui within cloud
console you can see this is working
software this is me querying prometheus
metrics and you can see them returning
to the screen um
we also have full grafana compatibility
so you can see this is me uh just
changing the data source from local to
foreign and it just works nothing
changes uh so this is great for you as a
customer terrible for me as a presenter
because really nothing should change
when you swap from your local prometheus
to manage service for prometheus as your
data source it should be exactly the
same data and that's what you're seeing
right here
so let's do a brief comparison of cloud
monitoring because uh we do now have two
products within the same area
so there are two products coming out
around the same time there's google
cloud managed service for prometheus
which is google's recommended way to run
prometheus at scale and there's cloud
monitoring and the upcoming gke workload
metrics which is google's recommended
way to monitor kubernetes applications
so maybe another way to think of this
might be if you as a customer if you're
saying to yourself you know what i don't
want to deal with any monitoring
infrastructure whatsoever i want google
to manage everything for me and i want
to get the best practices
of google monitoring and google sre's
philosophy built into my monitoring
infrastructure i think cloud monitoring
and gka workload metrics is the product
for you if you're saying to yourself you
know what i like prometheus i like the
prometheus ecosystem i want to keep what
i have already i just want to outsource
the hard part of metric storage and
retrieval scaling then manage service
for prometheus is the product for you
another way to think of this might be
how much do you want to be managed so
with managed service for prometheus you
get scalable collections global queries
and long-term retention included as a
managed service of course with open
source interfaces whereas with cloud
monitoring and gk workload metrics you
also get alert management dashboarding
and unified metrics logs and traces as
managed services as well
remember because we're using the same
back end and share a lot of the same
apis swapping between these is pretty
easy so you're never locked into your
decision you can choose the best
solution for you at any given
time we are in preview right now we
expect to be in general availability
sometime early next year but we would
love to have you in preview you can sign
up at g dot co slash cloud slash manage
prometheus once again that's g dot co
slash cloud slash manage prometheus
so i'm going to turn it over to bartosz
now to talk about openx's journey with
manage service for prometheus in preview
hi my name is pato jacobski and i'm
senior devops engineer at openx
openex is a global advertising exchange
we handle over 200 billion dynamic
requests per day
in 2019 we've completed our move from
on-premises servers to gcp
before moving to cloud we've had a
custom monitoring solution which is
based on graphite and used grafana for
visualization
we've used migration gcp as an
opportunity to update our monitoring
stack to promise based solution
we're a global company so our our
monitoring spends many gta clusters and
multiple gcp regions on free continents
and right now we ingest over 350 000
samples per second
we do use cloud metering too many for
metrics from services managed by gcp
when it comes to prometheus we run what
i'd call a pretty standard global
permafuse setup
we use thanos for long-term storage of
metrics and global view
we do use grafana with about 100
dashboards right now
and majority of our alerting works on
data from more than one gpa cluster so
it's usually quite global
and we store about two years of metrics
right now
we really do like our stack grafana
prometheus and thanos work well together
in the cloud
most importantly
it just works
but there are some issues
running full tenant stack can be quite
an involved process
you can see here a list of tennis
components that are running in our
global observability cluster
you have to deploy manage and monitor
all of them
in some cases like with tennis store you
have to manually shard instances by time
to ensure they won't run out of memory
and performance will be adequate
scaling managing resource requirements
modifying sharding configuration is
something we have to do regularly
just keeping the lights on does require
work
for example kubernetes upgrades may
require modifications and manifests for
our components
there's always
some effort needed
we do have some performance issues
some of them could be solved by
modifying car setup but again it needs
time and resources to do so
due to large amount of components
involved our global alerting and
monitoring is a bit more fragile than
we'd like
also for
global setup inter-cluster connectivity
is required it is another piece of cloud
infrastructure that you have to set up
and secure yourself
also more components and more involved
setup means that more knowledge or more
time is required to make changes or fix
issues
why we decided to use managed service
for prometheus in preview
first as a company we are always
interested in reducing complexity and
maintenance burden
one way to achieve that is by using
managed services instead of rolling out
and maintaining our own ones
another reason is
from a few query language compatibility
this is a big selling point for us
complete migration to any other query
language would require a major effort
and ability to run unmodified queries
makes the move possible
self-managed collector is just
prometheus
you just deployed like you deploy your
regular prometheus it can run alongside
your prometheus and to do so it only
requires small changes in existing
configuration
so we installed collectors now
production clusters
gather some data
added data source to grafana
and we got the same graph basically
so
it turns out
that crafting dashboards indeed do work
we do use
more advanced promql queries in some
places and their compatibility is pretty
good too
so
what opportunities for openex managed
service for prometheus
provides
this is a simplified diagram of
components that we are running in our
global monitoring stack
if we were to move to many services for
permifuse in transitioning period when
we will still need access to our older
data in cloud storage bucket some
components can already be eliminated
once we are fully migrated to manage
service for permafuse most of the
components will disappear with only
prometheus collectors remaining
this reduction in complexity will get us
some time back
we will no longer need to adjust storage
volumes and resource requests there will
be no need to modify sharding internal
store instances
fewer components means fewer incidents
caused by problems in alerting a
monitoring system
last but not least
better integration with cloud monitoring
would allow us not only utilize cloud
metering tools like slo alerting but
would also simplify and streamline
access to metric data
no more combining two query languages in
single graph in rafana to combine
our application metrics with for example
load balancer metrics
thank you for letting me share my openx
preview story with you
now back to lee
thank you bartosz once again we would
love to have you for the preview you can
sign up at g dot co slash cloud slash
manage prometheus
uh thank you for watching
you